all right i've got a message for
everybody today listen very carefully
here i don't want to be misunderstood
i don't care if you want to wear a mask
forever
and what i mean by that is i don't mind
it doesn't bother me
it's no skin off my back it really
doesn't bother me at all i'm not going
to think twice if you want to wear a
mask forever or for years
or indoors or outdoors or whatever i
have
no interest whatsoever in telling
anybody
not to wear a mask or worrying about
people who plan to wear masks
even beyond when the cdc recommends it
but
there are increasingly more and more
republicans
who are going off the wall with rage and
fury
that other people want to keep wearing
masks
now this is actually a really big topic
because fundamentally
this relates to the psychology of the
pandemic pandemic induced ptsd
agoraphobia fear adjustment and a whole
bunch of different things that i'm glad
to talk about
in a moment but fundamentally this
reaction from the right is the absurd
hypocrisy of people who constantly claim
for decades they've been claiming we're
about liberty
individual freedoms letting people do
whatever they want as long as it doesn't
infringe on someone else's freedom to do
what they want
they are all about letting others do
whatever the hell they want to do
and they will not stop talking about
others who want to keep wearing masks
of no consequence whatsoever to tucker
carlson
or to whoever doesn't want to wear a
mask
let's look at some examples here is a
recent headline from a fox news uh
tucker carlson interview
with brit hume called quote some people
want to wear their masks forever it was
a segment
dedicated to ridiculing and criticizing
people
who may be vaccinated but want to
continue wearing a mask
here is a segment from fox news where
reporter
peter ducey either feigns confusion
or is really confused about why joe
biden wore a mask inside a ford auto
plant earlier this week
despite being vaccinated and despite the
cdc guidelines now saying you know
vaccinated people really don't have to
wear masks
in most situations including indoors
let's take a look at this segment
but the president is saying a lot by
showing us what he's wearing we have
some new video you can see
at a electric vehicle plant in dearborn
michigan he has got a face mask
covering his mouth and nose which
conflicts with the cdc guidance that
you don't have to do that or socially
distance indoors or outdoors as long as
you are vaccinated
which the president has been since
before taking the oath of office
now when it comes to that specific event
with joe biden
at the ford plant and i believe it was
michigan remember that the cdc
guidelines are not state policy
and the cdc guidelines have not yet been
made state policy in many places and
state policy and state law
supersede recommendations from the cdc
at the end of the day they're just
recommendations
and of course ford it's not just
michigan ford may well still have a
policy
that everybody's masking indoors
regardless of vaccination status
many retailers still do etc but
fundamentally putting that aside
who cares if other people want to wear
masks as i've said before
i don't believe the outdoor masks were
ever really necessary
in almost any situation but i did it in
order to be a team player
because those were the cdc guidelines
and or
state guidelines and as soon as the cdc
said masks are no longer recommended
outdoors for vaccinated people
i haven't worn my mask outdoors since
other than in specific situations like
waiting in line to get into a grocery
store where the grocery store recommends
it
now that the cdc has said basically
every activity for vaccinated people is
low risk
i'm seeing other vaccinated people and
the truth is
everybody i know is vaccinated at this
point but i'm seeing vaccinated people
indoors we're not wearing masks i've
even sat inside of some cafes
but when i see people outside wearing a
mask i don't care i don't give it two
seconds of thought
if i if i devote some thought to it i
might wonder well
maybe they're not yet vaccinated okay so
they're wearing a mask
maybe they have a particular situation
medically
where they are at risk or maybe they
just like covering their face or maybe
they're afraid because it's been 14
months of this and it takes time for
people to readjust
or whatever who cares just because it's
not the cdc recommendation and just
because i'm not doing it what do i care
if other people are doing it
as long as they're not berating me to do
something that is not part of the cdc
recommendation so this is yet another
one of those instances
in which the hypocritical right wingers
claim to have certain values
but they don't stand by them when the
rubber meets the road
now the other reality we also should
mention
is that any guidelines where there is a
degree of nuance
where you need more than one sentence
it's probably too complicated for the
people that watch
fox news so it wouldn't be surprising to
me if the reason
imagine that we looked and like maybe
michigan has pulled the
mask mandate and maybe ford did too i
don't know it looks like everybody was
wearing a mask there so ford probably
requires it but imagine that ford said
you don't have to wear masks if you're
vaccinated michigan said the same thing
if fox news viewers turn on the tv
and absent any context they just see joe
biden walking around with no mask
many of them are going to immediately
take their masks off in all situations
even around vaccinated people because
they don't understand what the hell is
going on so
in some sense you could make the case it
makes a lot of sense for the president
of the u.s
to keep wearing the mask when he's going
to appear on tv and in public
so that unvaccinated fox viewers don't
see it and assume
they're clear to just do whatever the
hell they want
despite not being vaccinated and despite
being indoors around other unvaccinated
people so
first of all i don't care what other
people are doing with their masks
power to them to do whatever they want
but at the same time because we have so
many ignorant people in the united
states
in a way it kind of makes sense that
this is exactly
uh what joe biden would be doing so come
on guys just live your life get yourself
vaccinated follow the cdc guidelines
don't worry about what other people are
doing let them do whatever they want
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique
online service delivering the same
active
ingredients as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription
the medication comes straight to your
home within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping